Alex folks Nazi as far as pound for
pound is number one in the world as far
as straight skill set is by far the best
145 around the planet he's also the
second best if not the best lightweight
on the planet how about that how about
them apples
now Brandon
and it is Monday morning July 10th
coming in hot
coming in very hot off of UFC 290
pay-per-view
uh I would say by far the best full card
pay-per-view we've had in a hot second
by far the best of 2023 best in memory
so far for me I mean it was top to
bottom just a real pleasure the whole
thing was just fantastic my word uh so I
was I was excited to come in today and
talk about this card
um this card was so good I could have
done a recap right after the freaking
fights I was hyped up it's hard to sleep
when the fights are this good man just
the whole card the whole freaking card
uh from Robbie Lawler Beau nickel hooker
dreikas duplici's pantosia volkanovski
there's so many freaking story lines
going on the Real Housewives of the UFC
is popping right now with all the drama
all the storylines phenomenal fights you
have Robbie Lawler the great one
retiring the UFC finally got it right
gave him a proper send-off my God was
that a proper send-off if you had a dry
eye you are a communist uh Robbie Lawler
just man uh the legend and did it on his
terms and did it the right way and they
gave him full kudos for that which he
deserved a guy who is basically RoboCop
who doesn't show any emotion was
emotional in the octagon and uh man it
was it was uh it was cool to see man
that's how they should do it and I think
UFC they've gotten blow back before
right in the like sometimes the way they
sent off Shogun right you like said it's
like dead man walking you can just give
him some nightmare of a match up and
then send him on his way
um
they got it right with Robbie Lyle even
though he was a dog in this fight
against Nico price anybody that bet
against him like moved to North Korea if
you bet against Robbie Lawler moved to
North Korea dude that first rule of
Fight Club don't bet against Robbie
Lawler I know he's had fallen some tough
times that you never bet against Robbie
Lawler that is the first rule of Fight
Club or Dan Henderson if you're American
we don't bet against those guys no
matter who they're fighting so shout out
to Robbie Lawler man
um yeah just the whole freaking card Bo
nickel dude but Bo nickel did to that
Valentine Woodburn
um was offensive it was offensive and
that's exactly what should have happened
now
I will say this uh you know no one's
high on Bo nickel he is our Lord and
savior uh he's the great white hype I
can't remember a guy of his caliber in
DC allude to it on the broadcast he goes
He if there's a blue chip or he's our
blue chipper I can't think of a guy at
his level that had this much hype
um and promise that I was this excited
about with Connor
it was different because he's coming
over uh uh from uh cage Warriors for
cage Warriors as a champion and there's
a there's some hype on Rogue and I
alluded to him a little earlier before
that the fight world the hardcores knew
who he was he was coming in so he was
he was damn good already by the time he
got to the UFC with Bo nickel you're
talking about a guy
with his wrestling background that
dominant and then I think what adds to
his
kind of Uprising is people in the fight
game who are well respected like you've
never seen anything like this dude he's
talking about Jorge Mazda doll you're
talking about the ATT Team all of them
like I'm telling you man this kid is a
problem and it ain't just his wrestling
we're like really because usually you
know when a guy of his wrestling caliber
it takes a while to get comfortable on
the feet takes a while it's always a
liability you're always like yeah he's
gonna have to get the takedown but how
fluid bow nickel is uh you know it's
tough to say this but we've never seen
anything like it with a guy with only
five fights and fighting in these high
level fights you know beyond the main
card of this huge UFC
um we've just never seen a guy pass the
test this easily and look this damn good
like usually there's always something
you can you know the biggest knock on
him when he fought Jamie Pickett was
like oh you didn't get that arm triangle
fast enough you're like okay like oh man
he didn't lock it in right away it took
a little longer like okay and then you
know they put him against this Val
Woodburn who uh the UFC for whatever
reason obviously is a really short
notice fight the UFC capped um
kept harping on him being a landscaper
like every in the countdown just him on
those riding lawnmowers in Florida
cutting The Lawns off usually they shy
away from that the last time I can
remember they did a guy like this was my
boy
um Pat Cummins Pat Cummins was working
at a coffee shop and they really
remember when he got the call to fight
DC which you know was a tall order
um because DC was pretty established at
that time so he he had to call to fight
DC and he got the call by his coach
driving up to his uh drive-through
window at the Barista when he was the
Barista in the Cop Shop he's like hey uh
just got a call from Dan White fighting
DC he's like cool I [__] quit like
walked out and the coach picked him up
they kind of focused on that with him
and obviously that fight didn't go his
way
um and they kept saying what I find
interesting too and this dude Val
Woodburn all kudos to him to step up and
fight Beau nickel who's our basically
our LeBron James right now
um is insane on on that short of notice
only having seven fights you know
but it's funny that like it's going to
be life-changing like this guy gets to
call life changing it's like or he's
back to cutting Lawns tomorrow because
he got knocked out in 30 seconds there's
also that that's usually how these
things go it's very rare they bring in a
guy who's not UFC Savvy or UFC caliber
and I'm not saying he's not but he's
nowhere near a bow nickel level now if
he would have fought somebody else you
know that is in Bow nickel who knows and
they're going to give him that
opportunity that's one thing I think
they do promise it's like even if he got
knocked out in three seconds you still
get another fight that's how that's the
way they show respect because he did
give nickel the opportunity but to say
it's life changing it's like I don't
know Brad made 10 grand
10 grand he's back cutting lines this
morning you know now if you would have
won yeah yeah now you're talking about
something a little different Bo Nick is
not who he thought he was and then
Valentine Woodburn's in the UFC and he's
fighting other guys and trying to
become a contender you know that that
might be a different story but usually
these things go as they should and you
know you get dealt with in 38 seconds I
I think what was more surprising is how
comfortable Bo Nick was on the feet
um and again you're only talking about
three seconds so we're gonna see a lot
um so just the way he got it done I
think surprised everybody's surprise
wood but Woodburn didn't realize he was
getting punched in the face you know he
shot for that takedown on Woodburn which
I knew was going to be a bit of a
struggle because the Way Woodburn his
structure is short so it's tougher to
get to those legs but I don't think that
was a case of Bo nickel attempting and
failing I think it was attempt to set
him up for The Knockout that's what I
think was going on there
um but you know shout out to Beau nickel
well they do next with them
I think he's a top 15 I honestly
personally think he's the top 10 guy
right now but
um you again there's no sense in seeing
if he is you know even though if I say
that or the UFC brass thinks that
there's no point in pushing him into the
top 15 right now
um what you would do with a guy like
that is give give him not wood burns on
you know a guy who's cutting Lawns
coming off you know uh the regional
circuit but you'd give them more UFC
vets
um see how he does but at this rate you
know keep keep building it keep building
it boxing does this well keep building
the hype
um and keep building the star because he
has a pretty established fan base you
keep building that keep building that
and then when it's time you you put them
in there against the top 15 but at this
rate you know he could fight 10 times a
year you know just starching these guys
in 30 seconds but
um
I'm always an advocate for it's a
marathon not a Sprint take your time
with him I could see Sprint from a
little a little sooner than than some of
the other prospects and I think you'd
pass that test but there's no upside
there's only downside with that
um so I I do think you keep them uh you
know in the second gear they got him in
before we just launch them in the fifth
gear so I think you need another guy
that you probably never heard of next
but he's gonna have probably three or
four fights in the UFC probably a
winning record in the UFC and Bo nickel
is going to handle him and then there's
going to be more demand that he fights a
top guy it's weird the people that hate
on Bo nickel it's like what do you what
do you want him to do and it was tough
for it's tough for hate to hate him even
his post uh
fight uh not even an oppressor when he's
inside the hot gun and he's like hey
being a fighter is great it's all about
being a dad like you know and being a
good husband a good father like how can
he hate on the guy I guess it's American
Pie as they get dude he's just he's the
real deal on every facet man he's he's
the next face of the UFC I would bet a
lot of money on that I bet a ton of
money on that let's take a little break
kids from talking about all the Real
Housewives the Mixed Martial Arts
because guess what our friends at
DraftKings Sportsbook take your shot and
win huge with DraftKings Sportsbook you
could win big with money lines props
parlays and more if you bet on all the
underdogs or at least the three major
underdogs on this last UFC you're making
bank dude so right now new customers can
score 150 in bonus bets instantly for
betting just five dollars on anything
we're talking you got MLB popping right
now you got UFC this Saturday all right
you got NBA Summer League going on but
really you got baseball and UFC is
really all you need to know all right
um so again you can score 150 in bonus
bets instantly for about just five
dollars on any sport you want download
the DraftKings Sportsbook app right now
use code shop that's code shop only at
draftking Sportsbook gambling prom call
100 Gambler New York call 8778 Hope NY
or text Hope NY
467-369 in West Virginia visit
www.1800gambler.net in partnership with
Hollywood Casino at Charles Town Races
all games regulated by West Virginia
Lottery please play responsibly in
Connecticut help is available for
problem gambling call
888-789-7777 or visit
ccpg.org on behalf of Boot Hill Casino
Resort Kansas 20 or older in most
eligible States but age varies by
jurisdiction see draftkings.com
Sportsbook for details State specific
responsible gambling resources bonus
bets expire seven days after issuance
eligibility deposit restrictions apply
terms at
sportsbook.graphkings.com baseball terms
DraftKings this week at UFC Fight Night
yet uh MLB popping right now going into
the All-Star game make sure you download
the DraftKings Sportsbook app right now
use promo code you're welcome this
episode of the shop show is also brought
to you by the best on the planet I'm
talking about that Kratom Kratom for you
out there that never tried it now is the
time my friends at happy hippo that's
Happy hippo.com yep just like that thick
animal in Africa happyhippo.com promo
code is thick with three C's 23 you save
20 for life I'm talking about the
gummies the freaking powders they got
the instant shots which I use for every
single thing that I do helps me get in
the zone gives me that warm fuzzy
feeling we're not talking about like a
crazy energy drink no no we're talking
about creating get your focus for all of
life's Endeavors they got it all for you
right now they have that fast energy
they got the balance energy they can
slow it down for you again capsules
extracts powders flavored Kratom they
also got the Kratom K dips the first
ever Market pouches you know I like my
freaking pouches but when you talk about
Kratom pouches no one's ever done it so
my friends at happy hippo this is the
winter green the Razzle Dazzle they're
all phenomenal so whatever you're
looking for get it from Happy Hippo
Now's the Time to try Kratom all right
and you can go to happyhippo.com promo
code is thick23 for 20 for life you can
share with your friends use as many
times as you want and you can get 20 off
again that's Happy hippo.com promo code
thick23 you can use that promo code for
life to save 20 off the best freaking
Kratom on the planet the only people
that I trust is happy hippo that's Happy
hippo.com from coach dick23 let's get
back to the program
uh Dan hooker Jalen Turner hooker looked
fantastic
can't believe he ate that head cake that
was absolutely insane and it wasn't like
Jalen turn that an off night Jim Turner
looked like a world beater too you know
Miss weight which was a bummer but uh I
had Dan hooker win in the fight
definitely did Dan hooker that broke his
wrist how about Rogan goes what happened
to your arm he's like yeah it's just a
scratch but he told the ref don't raise
this arm that's how bad it was so Dad
hookers me out for a hot second with a
broken wrist but at least he's coming
off you know going into surgery with a
good win
and then the
I mean there would be it's tough to say
there's an MVP of that main card
obviously Bo nickel did his thing but he
found a guy you know he's cutting Lawns
last week Dan hooker you know fighting
11 verse 12 is a great fight
but can you name anybody in our space
that gave dreikas duplicates and the who
said he was going to win this fight the
only guy I know who stuck up for him was
the Schmo
when we did a fight companion
um and even off air I mean uh the Shmoe
talked about and he's like I'm telling
you man dude please he's a problem I was
like in what facet how do you see him
winning he's like he's just awkward and
you know his coach did say you know his
nose and get better and his Carter's
gonna be better I'm like come on this is
[__]
they lying you know so you know to doubt
uh drink his duplicity is insane it was
I but it's tough too
being with what we do to watch the
videos the footage on uh DDP and go this
guy's a world beater just because his
style is so different it's awkward at
times he looks like he's out of control
at times he looks like his head's over
his skis it looks like he's fighting
downhill at all times and the
technique's not perfect but for him it's
perfect he knows exactly what he's doing
but if you haven't seen that before I
think for people in our space or people
that watch a lot of fights you're just
like yeah this guy's just even you know
he doesn't look like a brad Tavares he
doesn't look like a Darren till he
doesn't look like a Derek Brunson does
it sure as [__] doesn't look like a
Robert Whittaker but it works it works
for him his style works for him he's the
only guy that can pull this off and uh
he's having success with it and I I
think too for Robert Whittaker hey
you're not going to get a guy to mimic
that fighting style which is a huge
Advantage for uh uh du policies you just
you're just not going to get a guy that
you can you're getting in real time it's
kind of like when one boy first came to
the UFC completely different style
obviously and you can bring in some
karate Taekwondo guys world champions
but when you mix in the MMA has you know
still wonder boy style was different but
he's at such an elite level
um
you know you can kind of mimic it but it
and you can get used to some Tendencies
but it's gonna be tough to get the exact
version of Wonder Boy and that's why I
had so much success early on [__] even
he beat Robert Whittaker you know at 170
but with uh duplicities it's just uh
it's it's hard if you've watched enough
fights go he does this really well he
does this really well this is world
class or this is world class but at the
end of the day it's world class because
it works for him I don't think there's
anybody else could do what he does and
have success and he hits like a Mack
truck that's the other thing I don't
realize how [__] biggie the guy was
he's a big tough son of a [__] man and
his cardio did look better his cargo
looked a whole lot better I think you
know at the end of that first round you
can see Robert Whittaker when he goes
his corn is just kind of like the hell
is this like he was just like I don't
know what's going on here man like he
knocked me down the [__] just a
straight right you know like you're
awkward not like will wind up just this
straight right like he just has that
South African strength I don't know
where it comes from you know you can't
teach that I think a lot of what he's
doing he can't teach and if you had a
young kid who was getting into MMA you
probably wouldn't show him a uh
duplicity's video and go this is
fighting because it looks like chaos to
the trained eye but for him it's not or
even the on-trained diet looks like
chaos but for him it's not chaos it's
just it's this beautiful Symphony and he
knows exactly where he's at and what he
should be doing when to press when not
to press and I you know after what he
did Robert Whittaker uh you know and the
guy's 20 and two so clearly this style
works for him you know so
um hats off hats off to to drink us to
policies you know there's there's not
much more you can say but we all got it
wrong I don't know anybody in the space
who picked him to win this fight I
couldn't think of a worse matchup for
him
um
I I think if you're looking at the glass
half empty here you go Robert Whittaker
didn't look the same maybe what Robert
Whitaker is older
I I think that's a cop-out I think you
just gotta own and go nah man uh DDP is
the real deal I think Robert Whittaker
you know you look at his fights before
this he looked pretty [__] good you
can't say this is an older version
Robert Whittaker I think Drake is
duplicates is that [__] good it's
time we start to acknowledge it does he
look like it is he no does he look like
a Wonder Boy God no does he look like a
you know Tyson Fury when it comes to
boxing does he does he have the kicks of
uh Yaya Rodriguez no man does he look
like Alex volkanovsky or you know even
Brad Moreno with his boxing God no what
he looks like is Drake's duplicates that
we've never seen and it's [__] good
and it's damn near impossible to beat
and now
and it's you know I'd love to talk to
his coach
you know hats off to them they've done a
great job with him in in tuning his
style and getting it to this world-class
level that and nobody believed in him
nobody but his coaches and probably his
few family members thought he was going
to be at this level
um
I would love to talk to his coach you
know when they talk about the five
percent breathing stuff like that and
then when you're like wait you wait till
you see him okay like because we I think
part of the problem is we're so Jade in
this business because Fighters come with
so many excuses and there's all this
[__] or you'll hear NBA player on my
my you know the reason I look bad is I
rolled my ankle this football player
says this or this fighter blames it on
this I'm like okay dude whatever
uh when you hear a guy he had surgery
and he only had five percent breathing
like eight percent eight percent I got
this such [__] dude but
do you see it you're like okay maybe
there's something here maybe they're
telling the truth here you know it's
when you see that he he looks so much
better and he did look like he was
breathing hard looked like Robert
Whitaker breathing harder like damn this
all right you gotta you gotta trust in
that now you know so I'm coming to his
next fight when he says something we
should probably listen a little better
now when it comes to his coach this is
where this fight gets interesting to me
so to police these wins oh the you know
beats Robert Whittaker completely
annihilates him that fight wasn't that
close the entire time Robert worker
could just never figured out the high
guard of duplicates nothing even the
check hook wasn't really Landing the the
light kicks were there a little bit but
overall duplicity's kind of controlled
that entire fight until he finished him
in the the middle of the second round
so then we know
part of the reason DDP was theirs you
know Izzy needs fresh blood and you know
he's beat everybody's beat Rob Whitaker
twice so you but I would still be
excited if Robert Whitaker won that
fight for that fight you're like all
right you can do it you know Rob workers
earned it he's probably the best moate
in the world not named Izzy I I get it
let's see if he can get over the hump
and it'd be good for Izzy right
so they have they're busy sitting cage
side and Izzy wants to go and you can
see the intensity of on Izzy's face when
that fight was going on Izzy was hoping
DDP won this fight
a little backstory there the reason why
Izzy was so upset now this is a we're
gonna get a dicey area here fellas
because and it's it's I'm not familiar
with the the politics of South Africa
and Africa and New Zealand and all that
[__] but I'll do my best here you know
I'm a dumbass let's see how this goes
but you know so
ddv's coach this is so insane we're
talking about this but this is that side
of the world
ddp's coach tweeted out before I I think
even
um
I forget when he when he it was on his
Instagram but he's talking about his
eight eight percent breathing and then
he's saying Izzy we're coming for you
you're not even a real African you know
check your passport you're the one that
moved out of here you're not a real
African the true Africans be champion
and that's when it gets dicey
and I think this is a a huge
it this is two-sided it's a I think it's
a a huge mistake by ddp's coach to go
that direction but then also I don't
know the politics out there I don't know
how that works right like does the the
South Africans feel that way like is
that a thing out there which I think it
is and for Izzy you got to realize you
know Izzy's from Nigeria right he's
Nigerian so you gotta remember Izzy was
born in Africa moved to New Zealand when
he's a young kid and got bullied because
he didn't look like the other kids in
New Zealand so he grew up with that fire
in his belly not fitting in getting made
fun of because he didn't look like a New
Zealander that made fun of him from
being from Africa so you have this kid
who was bullied from for not being New
Zealand right and and has you know
tremendous Pride where he comes from in
his roots in Africa and then
ddp's coach
that bear and it it goes deep for Izzy
you're talking about a guy that's what
makes Izzy who he is and so you're
you're kind of poking that you're you're
saying yeah you're not really an African
man you're [__] up I'm gonna tell you
this now because you know I do think
Izzy's the the best fighter we have on
the roster
and one of the things about Izzy if you
learned anything about his last fight uh
with Alex Pierre is when you give Izzy a
reason to to train you give him a reason
to focus and a reason to get up in the
morning and run those miles and put in
the work that it takes to be at his
level when you give him not only a
reason we give him the reason like Alex
Pierre was you know he was what 2-0
against him he hasn't beat him and then
he finally knocked him out insane insane
chin bet against him and piece of [__]
for it but I called it and your boy
called ins whatever it's whatever dude
this is different though this is this
goes beyond that because now you're
bringing in a cultural aspect to it and
you're you're you're touching nerves in
Izzy that haven't been touched before
and you you woke up the the sleeping
giant it just so happens that that
sleeping giant is the best in the world
and I and I don't think you could tell
like even for DDP he was uncomfortable
in that inside the Octagon when he was
saying you know when is he was saying
that n-word and he was like you're not
my brother you know you know all that
stuff I was like oh DDP was like what
the [__] did I do now on the other side
of it
remember DDP was coming off a Darren
Tailwind which you know obviously he's
not a world beater in any facet but a
good name but still you don't beat
Darren till then jump to Izzy but he got
in the news because the coach posted
that so it got the attention of Izzy
for good or bad it got the attention
Museum we're talking about it
in the UFC goes okay here's dick Branson
he beats him they keep that you know
they doubled down on it like okay and
Izzy's like I hope he wins I [__]
hope you really you I'm not from Africa
I'm not true African okay I hope he wins
and as he was saying I hope he wins
and then the UFC goes oh we got
something here
's Robert Whittaker here you go here's
Robert Whitaker good luck worst matchup
in the world but if you beat him we got
something here he beats him
y'all [__] up
because now and you can tell ddb and who
I want to see now if ddp's team runs
with this still because over there it's
getting a little dicey and last time we
had kind of a cultural War like this
Conor and uh khabib if you remember that
that guy where like there's there's
there's [__] talking and then when you
cross the line that's when it goes you
know when Connor's talking about Muslims
and stuff like that and kids and it you
know it gets weird he you know it goes
beyond the sport now if you the UFC
Dana's like evil like yeah yes right but
uh you know I'm just curious if ddp's
team now is gonna let's pull back on
that it's too late it's too late you're
you're dealing with a an African
elephant and Izzy that never forgets and
will find if you give him a reason to be
motivated and focus and bring out the
best and Izzy my god did you do it I
think it's it got you the title shot but
your coach [__] up
your coach [__] up I really believe
that I think you woke up a sleeping
giant and you get the best version of
Izzy boy is that tough to beat now I
think we've all learned in this space
don't doubt duplicates the guy has
skills that being said I I it got you
the fight kudos
be careful what you asked for be careful
what you asked for so it's interesting I
would love I would love if they just had
a a camera a cave-site camera on Trump
when when Izzy kept saying the n-word
he's like what is happening right now
what is going on right now you know he's
probably gonna understand the politics
of South Africa he's like why does he
keep calling the n-word why is he not
his brother and you could see Dana like
explaining the fight so he's like
actually here's what's happening and
Trump's like oh this is insane you know
so
um
I think it's the best fight to make and
you know Izzy's fighting in two months
so I don't know
um I would assume duplicis takes the
fight and he's gonna be fine he didn't
take much damage in this fight and it's
not going to come around often
um what the USC could do is they because
it's two months they could do a
Strickland
in the meantime that would kind of kill
the hype though right I agree I think
they got a strike with irons hot and if
your ddps came out you know with his
fighting style he's you know looking at
it in the way beat Robert Whittaker yeah
he he's a top three guy he just is we
got to give him his credit so
um but you know it's so tough to get a
title shot it's so tough I think you
just gotta all right take a week off get
back into camp or take three weeks off
you're in good shape then let's get back
into camp start focus on Izzy
um that would be their best shot the
only way I don't see that happening is
for whatever reason has some injury that
happened in Camp coming into the fight
and he wants to rehab that then they
would probably go Strickland
the Strickland one's interesting too if
you know the stuff strictly instead on
Rogan
um
it's tough to Market
it is what it is it's tough tomorrow
it's very negative right so it like a
lot of that's it's like a dark cloud you
know
um I do think Strickland gets a shot but
I don't think it will be in Australia I
I think people would be very
disappointed if it's not duplicates yeah
because now that thing's gonna sell no
matter what whether it's Strickland or
duplicious but I just think there's
gonna be more hype around if it's two
police 100 right now I mean he beats
Robert how how do again it's just all
predicated if he got injured during Camp
because in the fight he's gonna be fine
to fight in two months so we don't know
if he had injuries in that camp that he
wants to rehab or whatever but to do
this in Australia and have that
background that weird dark energy of
you're not African oh
man
sign me up and I'm curious if again if
because do policies look like he was
uncomfortable with all this he didn't
look like huge you know it just it
looked a little uncomfortable like he's
like oh [__] yeah here we are my coach
said that and I gotta I gotta defend
this good luck man it seems like that
was what they pushed in the beginning
but then they backed off a lot or at
least two places did and now Israel is
going with it oh I'm telling you [__]
up you're talking about a guy that
doesn't forget he's a baby elephant he's
a baby African elephant so whether you
want to ride with it or not you might as
well go full heel with it and build this
fight up because if you start back off
like yeah listen we made some mistakes
he's actually we realized he's from
Africa get the [__] out of here because
you said that is he's not gonna let it
go so you might as well lean into him
build this fight up then after about you
dude I was just trying to sell tickets
but right now I have uh if I'm advising
him it's gonna be painful you need a lot
of hate dude and he I heard even in uh
like any anytime you post anything in
the comments like oh the real African
like making fun of them you know so
you're gonna have to lean into that you
got to be the heel for Izzy here
especially if you want to build this
fight sell the tickets because you can't
go back you've always crossed that line
and Izzy's not gonna let you forget it
even if you apologize right now it does
not matter Izzy is fired up dude he's
not gonna let you drop it so you might
as well do it
have he loves the crown man you're gonna
be champ that's what's gonna take
that and that's an interesting fight you
know I'd love to see if Izzy can figure
out this weird
awkward Rubik's Cube that is DDP you
know this weird weird Rubik Cube we've
never seen before looks like he's you
know skating downhill and he's flailing
but he's not it's world class it's world
class so I can't wait for that [__]
fight now I can't wait for it
you know if it would have been the
decision it's like back and forth
controversial against Robert you're like
ah gas man no everyone was he's
surprised and impressed [__] them dude
it was crazy beat the [__] up Robert I
know of all people hear you
so so just already got bow nickel Dan
hooker great fight Rodriguez duplicity
did the goddamn thing as the big dog and
remember last week I said this is a
fight this is a card of mismatches well
a lot of those and to make the card fun
you see I said the mismatches had to win
that's what you got Robbie Lawler
mismatch nothing about this just before
we even get to the big dogs Robbie law
gets done 38 seconds Bo nickel knockout
38 seconds then you get Dan hook or
Jalen Turner crazy fight phenomenal
fight and then DDP comes out beats the
show Robert Whittaker you're like what
is going on right now the hell are they
gonna be with this then pantosia Brandon
Moreno come out
my family's obviously super Mexican also
if you listen last week I said it could
be a rough night for the Mexican culture
this was a rough [__] night
um
you know pantosia the guy's just doing
it all you know he beat makitao right
y'all you know what that how that goes
man is some you know I was watching
vokanasi versus and I don't I don't know
if I uh who knows where I got it I don't
know man I don't know who knows it's on
me but sometimes that [__] happens brain
farts man it happens to the best yeah
wish we had a computer could bring that
[__] but that's on me dude that's on me
um what's weird is obviously when I said
I think I said I'm fired the kid Brian
doesn't [__] know I could say he
fought Francis Brown be like unreal dude
that is unreal he beat Francis and God
I'm like yes at 125 pounds he [__]
ripped the Lego Francis Brian bug I
remember that so that Brian I don't know
fault on Brian but I think I even said
it during Dominic Cruz interview no one
picked it up I think because you were so
you just said with such conviction it
just we didn't even think about it yeah
maybe back in the day they did fight no
I don't know no man he's 125 pounds
that's insane all of us [__] up yeah
like between YouTube usually I would
like up but at that point I had that's a
big statement man
you might want to lay low for a little
bit
uh Rick killed a guy you might want to
lay low but yeah the entire uh staff
including myself just wrote on that
thing so [__] happens man but for
pantosia uh you know not a fan favorite
coming into it I told you guys I think
he was the most talented guy not to
become Champion
um you know had two wins over by Moreno
but it was that was a while ago
um
you know there was a lot of hype coming
into this fight for the guy and then you
watch the fight
when it comes to the judging this this
is what messes me up
is I probably
judge it the way you guys did before I
talked to Dominick Cruz you know months
ago and he said there's a companion he
goes you know all of us have to sit in
and even uh Laura senko talked about
this she sat in with the judges and how
they score it and damage is their number
one criteria when it comes to judging
damage is number one so that made me sit
back okay I gotta start judging fights a
little different because I used to
always judge the take down the control
whoever's controlling the fight whoever
you know is landing the more takedowns
is probably gonna win in a decision that
that's probably gonna be the victory
Victor most of the time but I gotta I
gotta reassess that because if Dominic
Cruz who's probably the brightest mind
in the game Laura sankow who's a [__]
B senko is a beast she knows her [__]
they've all sat in on the actual judging
criteria and they said damage is number
one all right I gotta recalibrate the
way I look at fights so I went into this
card with that in mind and even though
Bram Reno he was having a success in all
the rounds early on set for the first
round right second round he almost got
the Finish did the most damage close one
to get in the Finish
third fourth and fifth I think the fifth
he lost he was lighting up on the feet
but got taken down controlled a little
bit in the fifth
a year ago or even six months ago I went
this is what are you talking about Penn
tells you all day control them got the
takedowns was way more success on the
takedowns wouldn't do a lot of damage
with the takedowns but he controlled
them
pantoza won the fight
probably three rounds to five easily
three out of five rounds goes panto this
is easy but when you judge it based off
Damage Done
and that's the way I'm told they're
supposed to judge the fight I gave it to
bran Moreno I thought Moreno won the
fight
based off that judging criteria which
I'm told by judges and two of the
smartest Minds in the game that they
base it off damage done if you watch
that fight you know well Brian Mayo def
did the most damage
and not to mention dude had a broken
hand broke his hand the first round
so kudos to Brand Moreno
um So based off that knowing what I know
and talking to people in the game I get
to bring Moreno
you know there you go bro suffered hand
broken hand first round of the fight
um
but it but again you know the judging's
all over the boy are those judges basing
off that I you know it's weird it's
weird man
you look at the copy strike numbers you
know it shows brand Moreno
um but then you look at the control you
look at the the takedowns that's
pantosia so it's a tale of two stories
different stories you know I can see how
they gave to pantosia based off the old
judging criteria yeah you get the most
takedowns controlled the fight become
straight Damage Done you'd have to give
to Brian Moreno so I thought that's how
they were going to do it I really did
and the the I gave it 46.49 for brand
Marino people like that is ridiculous
like not it's not if you're judging
based off Damage Done
so who knows you know I just I literally
just watched it like intensely and then
I just felt overall
but then that's not how the rules you
know that's not that's not how you judge
a fight you got to judge it round by
round but I I seriously thought he won
most rounds I don't know I again I
thought he did the most damage so if
we're judging fight off most damage done
in the closest to finish the fight it'd
be brand Moreno if so Brett Moreno won
the brand Moreno won the fight pantosha
won the contest does that make sense
yeah
well I'll tell you what
even though it's you know there's not
this English isn't great but you can't
help but be a pantosia fan after that
that uh in the in the oh my gosh that
made me cry oh when he was like Dad are
you are you proud of me now yo
his dad abandoned their entire yeah dude
you're like whoa this is heavy yeah I'm
a fan dude I dude I wouldn't have bet
against pantos if I knew he had daddy
issues this is [__] I need to know dude
if I knew his dad left him and he had
that [__] fire in his belly to prove
his dad wrong I would have took pantos
all [__] day dude what you guys just
left that out his father just dipped out
I was like y'all are losers man I'm out
of here then becomes world champion and
gets on the mic he's like you're proud
of me now girl
I was like oh that's my guy now yeah he
had a shitty dad that didn't believe in
you and your world champion now how can
you not like the guy then then his wife
is there and all like you had so many
kids but they're all happy as [__] and
he goes this is my crew oh he's all
about family he's a good dad I had no
idea too man no the UC didn't tell that
story now your grand I don't know I
don't think anybody knew the story I
guarantee that's where he's gonna come
out now they're probably gonna go in the
Favela where the [__] he's from they
interview the dads asking like this is
[__] I always knew he's gonna be
Champion give me 10 percent
terrible
um as far as what's next for pantosia
I mean am I crazy I think it's another
brand Moreno fight even though he's 0-3
against him it's kind of like that that
Izzy ox-pierre thing it's like no I know
he's on I get it he's on three I get
that but Moreno we can see him how he
could win this fight he's also the
biggest name in the division
um
and uh like you saw your figuritos out
he's fighting Dominic Cruz by the way
see you have he's jumping in a different
weight class he's gonna fight Dominic
Cruz and I asked Dom he's like we'll see
maybe you know we'll see we'll have
energy I'm recovering Dom you can give
me a song like you know I'd like to
fight figurito even you know probably
signed the deal when you said that
whatever but so figured it was out he
was number one so Brandon Moreno would
drop to one
um Amir alabezi's there Brad Rory Val
you know pantojo has a win over roval
um go to pantoja's uh record for me chin
because I'm pretty sure he beat a mayor
too
having fought a marriage so he could do
a mayor
see lost a figarito or already so he's
beat bran Roy Val he's beat ask her off
even though it's all in three I think
you do Bram Moreno
I've and Bram Ray is the face of Mexico
boy Mexican Champs everyone's like dude
Mexico they got three Champs gone
now you have Alexa grow so that's it all
on electric right so now and Brad Marino
like it was such an opportunity for him
to become like this Superstar you know
this International Superstar
so I you know there's there's just
if I'm the UFC business-wise and just
what I think is the right thing to do
you have to pray Moreno that's what even
Dana want to talk to that Canadian
reporter Aaron bronstetter and he was
like would that be the next fight he's
like dude this fight was so amazing who
wouldn't want to see that you know the
next even though Brandon Reno has those
what Quadra quadrilograms what do you
call it three what would Davis and
figure out I know four times yeah so why
not again yeah exciting what else you
can do in that fight I I think if they
fight again Moreno beats him
knock on wood
unless pantos dad comes to the picture
you know yeah so I yeah I would give it
to I'd love to see a brand Marino
Pantoja for the fourth time even though
he's Owen three this is just different
it's just different
Rodriguez
it was funny some guy was talking [__]
to me because I was like vocalypse
there's no one at 45 she's ever gonna
beat him it's not it's not not done yet
I Rodriguez it's just never gonna happen
and the guy's like Oh shot picked
smoking obviously I'm definitely taking
our Rodriguez I'm like cool dude put all
your money on yeah Rodriguez let me know
how it goes for you
it's just it's not a knock on yair it's
not a knock on uh Brian Ortega it's not
a knockdown any you know Josh Emmett you
know whoever it is it doesn't matter
there's not a guy at 145 pounds walking
this Earth who's ever going to beat
rokonovski right now in the next five
years now once he gets older you have a
better shot right now after watching his
fight against Michael which some people
thought he won the way he made that
thing competitive the way that he showed
his strength
I want everybody's [__] at 45. it's
never gonna happen
he's too calculated he's too smart he's
too good at everything he's too much of
a professional and I know it's early to
say he's the best one 145 of all time
but he's the best 145 of all time you
know what the [__] he would do to a
prime Jose Aldo
you beat them so he's my goat I know
josela has more title defenses I don't
give a [__] about any of that stuff Alex
folks Nazi as far as pound for pound is
number one in the world as far as
straight skill set is by far the best
145 around the planet he's also the
second best if not the best lightweight
on the planet how about that how about
them apples he went toe-to-toe with
makatev nobody else can give muck each
of that fight
I think he beats anybody else at 155 not
in a market Jeff the Macha fights tough
I think he can't get over on him but you
know I just think at 45 there's just the
guys can't compete that wasn't even a
fight by the way guys that wasn't even a
[__] fight and that's why you're
coming off that Cobain event with
pantosia brand Moreno this epic fight
the two best in the world that's how
those fights should go very competitive
one guy's good at grappling Jiu Jitsu
the other guy's boxing is exceptional
and then you got to figure out the game
plan but one guy has success this round
the other guy has success this round
goes back and forth It's A War it's one
of the fights of the year
but in this case there's not a guy on
this planet volkanasi is gonna fight
that's gonna give him a tough fight it's
just not possible hate to tell you guys
it's not going to happen the next for
him was a homeboy was cage side
in uh topiria yeah
listen I'm I'm a huge topperia fan huge
I want to see Rodriguez till period
that's the best 145 in the world not
named Alex mokanowski
again I'm huge on topir this isn't a
knock on topiria
it's not competitive guys he beats the
[__] topir I know uh I know ileotopia
is undefeated stuff like I don't give a
[__] this ain't a competitive fight he's
a plus 400. that's just where we're at
right now
and also you're not going to get that
fight because
now he said he might come back in
October maybe he comes back in November
December he's gonna have surgery
but he's bounced back before from
surgeon comes back fast as [__] I I as
far as if you're gonna show if you're
gonna take one fight on a show somebody
who's professional who's like the Tom
Brady who's like the Cal Ripken who's
um you know the the Kobe Bryant of the
UFC it's Oxbow kanasi there's not a more
professional guy on this planet there's
not a guy more driven he has that very
GSP had the same thing where
clearly he
can beat Yaya Rodriguez however the [__]
he wants and he should go in the fight
going I got this but he finds something
GSP did this for every single fight he'd
find something the guy does really well
that makes him scared to train his ass
off GSB did that against kostjack he did
that against even Dan Hardy who he's a
massive favorite over he would find
something that would get him up in the
morning train his ass off Alex
volcanovski's the same way he finds one
thing that gets him scared and goes oh
it's gonna be a tough fight he trains
his ass off most guys that get to that
level they Coast a lot of them will
Coast or go ah it's about me but when
asking makes about the other guy he he
finds the one thing to make him scared
you know
very special very very special
the whole [__] card man what a fight
card yeah favorite fight card in a long
freaking time let's take a little break
kid kids uh what I got what I got for
you well what I got for you is the best
nootropic on the freaking planet from on
it that's right the number one selling
nootropic on the planet talking about
Alpha Brain you get at Walmart you can
get it all over Whole Foods they all
have it all right and if you good off on
it.com if you get it from the site you
save 10 off when you use the promo code
shop but also they have more than just
Alpha Brain they offer Alpha Brain Black
Alpha Brain instant Alpha Brain shot
Alpha Brain Black is what your boy uses
it's the highly concentrated Alpha Brain
so if you tried the regular Alpha Brain
which you should there's no reason not
to you get your money back if you don't
love it you can share it with a friend
you don't have to return the product get
your money back but if you want to Aid
in mental processing you want caffeine
freeing helps get in the Flow State
promotes Focus supports memory help
remember names like did marketev really
lose to pantosia I was not using Alpha
Brain that day focus on complex tasks
think more clearly under stress react
more quickly if you could use all that
try out Alpha Brain Alpha Brain Black is
the one I recommend that's on it.com
promo code is shop on
all on it products talking protein
powders Warrior bars streaming Fitness
kettlebells steel Club maces we got it
all but we also got the best nootropic
on the planet talking about Alpha Brain
on it.com receive 10 off you're welcome
let's get back to the program what do
you got buddy a lot going on the Real
Housewives of the UFC yeah so on this
fight card here's a news story from this
fight card so remember Jack Della
madalina so Jack was supposed to come on
the show tomorrow
but he's currently in Vegas because he
he's he's ready to fight there's a fight
there's a fight night Saturday night
Holly home
um versus Silva that card could use Jack
yeah so Jack's hope is that Dana White
finds him a fight just so he just stays
in Vegas and fights on Saturday yeah so
I just talked to his coach
sounds like they're gonna find him a
fight and um I was like obviously you
weren't going to but just know there's
no pressure on it dude I do not I know
how it is fight week definitely on
traveling even though it's short but
let's do it next week and after he beats
whoever it is up Jack's such a Savage
so remember his original opponent was
Sean Brady then he had that crazy elbow
issue with that fluid building up and I
love Sean Brady that Sean bravers Jack's
a great fight exactly yeah it would have
been an awesome fight and then he had
this newcomer
um Josiah Harrell who was supposed to
fight him as well but during the
pre-medical screenings he found out that
he has some rare brain disease that
needed medical attention if he would
have fight probably would have died he
could have had a stroke or something I
mean that would have been a catastrophe
for the UFC if you would have got like
head kicked and died before it goes
thank God for those pre-screens that
they they're serious about that stuff so
thank God so he's saying it's a blessing
in disguise and that's the reason why
Jack couldn't fight this weekend that's
a good reason not that yeah and then
Jackson get a fight even though it's not
Sean Brady you know but he'll still be
active yeah
um all right so the biggest news I think
over the week was uh Jon Jones versus
official now for UFC 295 in November
if you remember Trail thought it was
going to be in uh Australia Jon Jones
versus Sergey Pavel yeah
he's way off but then the next day we
got word that Steve I've known about
this for a while so I'm not you know I'm
not a journalist I don't break news but
I knew steepe John was happening at UFC
95 for a month now 295 yeah for a month
now
all right so that's pretty damn cool
tough fight for steepe yeah and this has
been all over the you know social media
everything but so Israel to Sanya during
uh International fight week met up with
Jon Jones and they kind of squashed the
beef they did like a little couple
videos together so that's pretty cool
yeah it was cool man yeah
and what like and when you look at that
look dude not small dude he's not small
I kept telling you guys that Jones is
Big yeah
but Izzy has sandals on dude and there's
you know oh yeah I didn't think about
that same height maybe you know but
maybe John's a tad taller but but he's
just so much bigger though John's thick
yeah John's thick right now
to the goats I like I love to see it
they're never gonna fight
no definitely not uh so that's another
video but everyone's seen this video
already but this right here was
interesting so Tyson Fury commented
I wonder if they have it here though
there it is so Tyson Fury made a
a story post he says Johnny Bones
imagine the amount of right hands I
catch you with here and he's looking at
the sparring video of the fake sparring
video
Tyson's best at marketing I've never
doubt myself this is John Johnson
let me just knock you out in boxing and
100 he knocked both of them out no so
this is Jon Jones responding to Tyson he
says I have no reason I thought myself
against any man give me a few months in
a serious boxing Camp I like my chances
I may just knock you yeah it's never
happening but it's fun to talk about but
what you are happening I got this info
last I text you guys again I'm not
drilling so I'm not gonna break news
like Ariel or something like that it's
just not what I do nor do I care to do
it but uh
Francis first Tyson Fury I got word now
remember last week's show where I oh
it's an exhibition match like what's
going on I was like that's a terrible
idea it's not the reason they say
exhibition is because someone in Saudi
or wherever they're doing it it's this
weird dynamic between the entertainment
promotion and the actual fight promotion
and the entertainment promotion was the
ones that were like behind it for a
little bit and the way they get around
dealing with all the commission that
stuff by Sansa exhibition but this is a
straight up real fight there's no
gimmicks there's no it's not sparring
not a glorified Spar match when this
goes down it's official when it goes
down in Saudi Arabia wherever they do in
the Middle East it is a straight up real
fight Tyson Fury Francis ingano straight
up boxing match
Francis ingano made the right decision
he's saying [__] all the haters all the
doubters now we know for a fact and how
he said this again I love friends he's
been on the show how many times I
absolutely love Francis but I stick by
it that in order when Francis left the
UFC if he didn't get this Tyson Fury
fight or Deontay Wilder fighter Anthony
Joshua fight it was a mistake he got the
fight it's official he's fighting Tyson
Fury the best boxer ever do it in a
legit boxing match
he made the right decision
shout out to to his agent you know who
took off Markel took all this [__] what
are you doing you ruin his career what's
up now what's up now you know yeah they
made the right decision they went they
crawled through some [__] like Andy
Dufresne they came out on the other side
another fighting Tyson Fury they're
gonna make all the money
there's no amount the pfl there's no
amount you know any other organization
the UFC could pay him that's gonna make
up more ground than him fighting Tyson
free Frank sangano Francis did it he did
it his way even though we haven't seen
it done this way a lot of naysayers
including myself went man if this Tyson
Fury fight which we didn't hear much
about it so it looked pretty Grim for a
while I thought oh man he's just gonna
find pfl guys we don't know this is a
nightmare even if he makes money how are
they gonna pay him who's he going to
fight what is he gonna do
shut up if I'm Mark I'm going but shut
up
yeah we knew this whole time this was
gonna happen it's very tough boxing is
tough to get into there's a lot of
different moving Parts it's going to
take some time just relax well what you
made a mistake and I didn't but everyone
else you made a mistake this is you've
ruined Francis ingano what's up now
shut up
they won they changed the game hats off
to them
now again I don't know what's gonna
happen with pfl I'm not saying that all
I'm saying from the standpoint of Team
Francine Gano and Markel they've won
they made the right choice to leave the
UFC this fight does not happen if he's
in the UFC Dana would not allow this to
happen even though he's entertained with
John and Tyson that fight's never
happening that's whatever
but as far as Francis goes
he beat the game dude we should all give
them him you know Francis Credit you got
to give more kill credit that guy went
through some [__] man you guys gave him
so much [__] he pulled it off nobody in
the history of Combat Sports has ever
done this he did it dude with the
heavyweight champion of the UFC he went
we're gonna leave the biggest promotion
in the world and bet on ourselves
more times than not this never works out
I can see a credit to those that doubted
him I get it I even I was like oh man
and we didn't get a lot we didn't hear
anything no no crumbles no seemed Tyson
Fury was like yeah it's not really
happening he's talking [__] to Jon Jones
then you know with the USIC fight and
all that we're like oh where's where's
Francis oh no it's not gonna happen now
we gotta watch him beat up some guy
we've never heard of him pfl
they'll give him all this money that's
gonna last one or two fights there's no
way they can cover that
I get it
they knew what they were doing shout out
to Markel man you did it brother proud
of you man and Francis my god dude
this is insane this is history dude
history now what but in this wild world
we live in the Real Housewives of mixed
martial arts a lot of Francis beats
Tyson Fury
no matter what happens he's won he go in
there and get knocked out by a jab in
three seconds and he should still make
the same amount of money does not matter
but if he beats him we're going Sizzler
and if you happen to be a Dana White
hater which I'm not very clear I'm a
huge Dana White fan but if you are you
want Francis ingano to win you want him
to win this gives every fighter more
leverage what Francis is doing is
leading the way for other Fighters that
are stuck that feel like they have no
voice they'll feel like the UFC is the
only show in town even if they're
mistreated what Francis is doing is he's
taking the hits for them going no no
look there is a way to do this there's
another route you can go
you just have to be really good at
fighting and knock out everybody you
fight though that's the that's the
asterisk there don't get wrong now if
you're two and two in the FC I'm not
talking about those guys but there is
another route he's showing us he's
changing the game you have got to give
him credit for that Francis made the
right choice it feels good to say that
you want him to win him winning is
better for the fighters
it's not better for the UFC but it's
better for the fighters so if you care
about the fighters you want to root for
Francis
one Markel one they changed history this
is a good thing
mm-hmm and I just I follow Markel and he
That's my boy yeah he puts some posts
out that he left uh CAA to start his own
business and he I don't know he has some
sort of heart condition he had to get
surgery hopefully he seems like he's
okay yeah he's recovering so yeah so he
solely works with Francis that's awesome
now they're gonna be coming out the
Woodworks to work with him oh my God we
knew you wouldn't have this all the time
really were you six months ago
and according to this article it takes
cojones dude yeah imagine the [__] he
went the [__] he went through remember
the taxi got yeah from Daniel the racist
tax I don't know no they were straight
up races I mean from a random source
I'm just saying yeah the [__] he went
through he went through some [__] it
must feel good and he still says he he
appreciates Dana White very much and for
sure yeah no issues but yeah so
according to the shows you can do it but
you have to walk through some fire you
have to bet on yourself 100 no backing
down bet on yourself and your fighter
yeah you have to like the relationship
between Francis and Markel is insane
like
uh you you would have to have so much
belief in each other Francis in Markell
major faith and and Markell and Francis
like there there has to be no [__] in
that armor that's to be no weak point
you have to trust the process my god did
they go through it sky's the limit now
fellas proud of them man
so I was not saying it this article says
10 to 15 or 10 to 50 times bigger purse
than the UFC but who knows what the
actual number is oh it's gonna be
massive I mean it's gonna be huge of
course massive especially if it's gonna
be a real fight now so thank God it's
real dude massive
massive bigger than anything the UFC is
going to do this year or the next 10
years bigger than any Jon Jones fight
bigger than Jon Jones Francis there's
they've won no matter Win Lose or Draw
Markel and Francis [__] one yeah it's
insane It's So Dope amazing yeah
okay so this isn't good if you're
McGregor fan I know what you're bringing
up this isn't good because the interview
from Aaron bronstetter with Dana White
and then this is Danny White's response
to the whole sort of thing with uh with
Conor McGregor versus
I hope so do you think there's still a
chance of them fighting this year 100
yeah
is Connor back in the usata pool from
he's not he's not okay so what do you
think he's not exemption it's gonna be
six months before he can compete again
um when he re-enters the the pool is
that something that the UFC is still
going to hold true to we'll we'll see
how that plays out I mean they're
they're saying that now but we don't who
knows
I don't talk about [__] until [__]
happens you know what I mean to sit here
and and think hypothetically how a
million different things could happen no
idea I'm focused on what's happening
this Saturday that's fair the next
Saturday and you know what I mean UFC
300 isn't even in my mind right now the
the Conor thing who the hell knows who
how that's going to play out
who cares what usada says we'll see what
happens when it happens
um so I don't know one thing we can talk
about is so the main point of that is
like who Dana White did say who cares
what usada says it's taking out a
context though because you remember that
article
uh Angry responds with Crystal me
Russian when he says who care he's
saying as of now there's no news who
cares what Conor says who cares what
usada says who cares what this person
I'd say who cares what the expert none
of it matters I'm putting one fire at a
time who cares what they're saying right
now not saying who the you it doesn't
matter what it says I don't like usada
thing you thought I ain't [__] that's
what they want to write in the reports
I'm with Dana on this he's going no no
I'm focused on UFC 290 right now who
cares what everybody's saying like you
said you don't care what yusata says you
can do whatever you want he's like no no
all of it who cares until I have to come
and deal with that I don't care about
what you guys say what the media is
saying what podcasters I don't give a
[__] about all that that's all you're
saying yeah so act the one of the I
think the post fight press conference he
did basically say that statement yeah
that's not what he meant anybody with
half a brain can figure that out but
again that's not gonna get a good
article at clicks yeah what gets clicks
is him going [__] you son who cares
about usada no he's not saying that he's
like what I'm who cares about any of
this right now
and also Connor tweeted this and deleted
it someone asked him I guess a fan asked
him tell us when the fight with the
Chandler he posts Emoji of Santa he was
December and then he deleted it but then
he put this as well
yeah I listen I could see the Conor
fight happen in December that's you'll
be announced I think the UFC well Trump
usata and go they were using the
exemption he's fighting we don't give a
[__]
that's what's going to happen I mean
they're going to drop them back I
remember you said that from the
beginning very beginning but I thought
like we started it was in stone you have
to do six months but yeah then I'm
coming by the UFC it's Connor he's
fighting
like wait he was in a protocol for six
months shut up
and get Connor knows this Dana knows
this usada doesn't know this
but I guarantee you kind of knows all
right I'm fighting December that's why I
see him right now not you know you see
him wilding out and doing his thing he
was like he's not even trained because
you know he's not fighting to December
so happened this year yeah it is you
think Dana's Gonna Let The Ultimate
Fighter run its course and they don't
fight till sometime next no no no he
knows he can just Trump you side and go
he's fighting
and hey hell yeah we're all gonna watch
I'll say it so [__] you Sada how about
that
yeah uh so tomorrow Usman was oh just
fight arms on
so they did like a Legends panel during
the international fight week Kamara was
their you know Chuck Liddell is there a
bunch of people you're our favor
um so Camaro said that he thought the
fight was still on he still wants to
fight hamzat and then hamzai responded
with this holy [__] his beard looks fake
because they're so yeah they're so funny
it look it just it looks like it's uh
about me
you said you want to fight 84 kilos
which no problem for you
you're a boogeyman
but I'm the wolf
come up
[Music]
I don't like the zooming in stuff but uh
I was like scared of him like all I'm
bored and now it's like hey remember
you're gonna fight yeah it's been like a
year dude what's going on here there's
contenders there's a million fights for
him at the end of the day it falls on
you dude at the end of the day it's like
at first it was like no one will fight
them they can't get them fights now it's
like he he still fight man and that
conspiracy you're talking about right
yeah could be
we'll see
and you hear other guy's like yeah I
tried finding them I don't know just
didn't happen everyone's like it just
didn't happen
here ladies like you find the Boogie I'm
the wolf you're like what's fight dude
are you gonna fight yeah we're online to
see him it's such a mismanaged career
whether it's his fault the UFC's I'd be
willing to lean into it more on his side
because UFC's like yeah let's whatever
man let's just [__] fight and he's
like well hold on here
yep let's let this pass first and see
what happens but yeah I hear what you're
saying
um your boy Marlon Cheeto Vero has a new
opponent it's fighting next week Pedro
Munoz 295 I know he's fighting in Boston
yeah yeah
[Music]
I mean yeah it's a far cry from uh
from paid from uh our boy Henry sahuto
but you know fun fight
alrighty
this is just a quick one where Dana
White reacted to Jon Jones me and I
if they can be around alcohol I thought
it was more than 12 hours a thing he's
taking shots like does that kind of get
you worried
[Laughter]
listen he's a grown man he can do
whatever the hell he wants um I always
say this John
more than 12 hours in Vegas is usually
probably not a good idea for John
um but uh yeah I don't know listen John
has done very well for himself he's he's
been through a lot of [__] you know
let's see I don't know whose idea it was
to keep John here for days but uh Hunter
was that your idea
[Laughter]
I'll just go well here we are I'll plead
the fifth on that sir
yeah he was taking shots with uh Jorge
miles at all
[Music]
but so far he seems fine yeah the last
two times that he's been in Vegas and
drank seems fine
so that's good
I thought this was pretty cool Michael
bisbing is going to be I guess he was in
the first den of Thieves with uh Gerard
Butler like a side character he's gonna
reprise that role I think he has a
bigger role in this one that's dope yeah
Gerard Butler no shade Jacks yes yes his
wings doing the damn thing dude he's
getting a ton of movies yeah he's
crushing I love bizbing
oh this is a very quick one I'm not
going to show the fight but uh Dan
hooker way back in the day he fought
someone 100 pounds heavier than him a
heavyweight fighter and he beat him
under Pride rules yeah under Pride rules
God hookers are Savvy he's a real true
fighter he's straight up
black guy was
good yeah
uh all right so for the BMF belt
celebration part uh apparently Jorge
Mazda is going to be the one that's
going to be wrapping the BMF title
that's exactly how they should do it we
don't guys never fought before being
like you're the BMF it's like dude
you're an actor what are we doing here
the rock yeah yeah it's based off
you know Jorge Mazel that's exactly
should be having that BMF title out yeah
and he was the BMF winner so that sounds
right and he's and he said like whoever
the next winner is should put the belt
on the you know whatever I think it
should be Jorge every time it's his belt
it should be called the Jorge BMF title
yeah I'm down with that yeah he's he's
the BMF
uh speaking of Jorge miles at all so
this is the first
um
face off with Febreze over doom and
Junior dos Santos for that MMA bare
Knuckle Event
I'm all about this verdum looks in shape
dude I would not want to fight him
but so does JDS this is a good fight
Jorge's doing the damn thing he's yeah
he's putting on good fights hell yeah
and here's some footage I found of
Junior dos Santos right now
Jack
yeah he looks good too
of course Febreze oh
Fabricio posted that thing but that's
fabriso here
and he is a Savage dude he's 45 years
old
jacked it looks good yeah
he made fun of uh I think little nog
because he had hair
transplant stuff
but yeah
all right well I think we're almost done
here oh so so during the uh UFC Hall of
Fame ceremonies did you see the Hoy say
uh first of all Jose Aldo his emotion
that's how it should be man it's a big
deal let me just play with you play for
you but no audio but you can see him
just
yeah it's a crazy breaking down here
yeah he's taking it all in right now
yeah I love it yeah that was super
emotional it's a cool time but so cowboy
Cerrone was also inducted in the Hall of
Fame and then he he mentioned that he
made 10 mil 10 million dollars in UFC
and people thought that was already
pretty crazy and but his bonuses were
crazy let's not give me 900 000 bonuses
yeah it's not crazy though
I thought it was weird people like whoa
10 million you know you realize Cowboy
made the UFC Moore in his one fight
against Conor McGregor he made he made
the UFC more than 10 million just that
one fight
over that historic career 10 million
dollars over how many fights I mean to
me when you break it down it's not yeah
it sounds crazy because how long did he
fight it says 10 over his 10-year
fighting career two million dollars a
year
so you know a good living book yeah yeah
but I mean no hold on hold on it's a
million dollars a year hold on that's
not including taxes managers the fees
it's
you know fighting for a living yeah I
will say though are you probably taken
you know home probably I don't know 500
600 000 and then also I would assume
that was towards the later end of his
career we made the majority of his money
oh there it is so Tim there yeah they
point out right here 10 million dollars
a lot of money we're happy that someone
is happy with what he made but it's hard
not to point out that the gate for
cerrone's fight against Conor McGregor
at UFC 246 was 10 million dollars alone
the event sold 1.35 million
pay-per-views which is roughly 88
million dollars
as the B side to one of the biggest
fights of 2020 you should have made a
big percentage of that 10 million in one
night he didn't get a cut dude
um
again maybe you guys have a salty way of
looking at the UFC when I heard Tim oh
my God that's it for for Donald Cerrone
a legend of sports stepped up for every
fight the majority of that money was
made in probably these last three years
of fighting
I guess the way I was looking at it is
like he wasn't Champion he's just he's
like a guy that keeps fighting but he
fought all the big names no yeah all the
main events I think they all deserve way
more money for sure it's just when I saw
my God that's not good
it's [__] up yeah to me either it's
[__] up dude the guy dedicated his
life to this and any other sport if
you're at his level of celebrity you're
set for life Cowboy ain't Seth
you know he I think he did well with his
money building his Ranch and all that
stuff and he does a lot of other a lot
of other stuff right now too
hopefully yeah I'm pretty sure he's
pretty good man and he's doing acting
now too which is cool yeah I love Donald
yeah but that's pretty much it for
current events those are good cool those
were good hopefully our boy Jack gets
his fight on Saturday in Vegas Holly
Holm coming back
I'm curious what they're gonna do with
the division Terence McKinney is
probably my favorite fighter on the card
so excited when he fights he's on the
main card he kicks that off on ESPN Plus
tough guard man
but at least you got Terence McKinney
yeah he's always excited yes Holly Holm
Silva
that bandwid division they need to
figure out maybe we get a Ronda Rousey
return that's what I think happens UFC
300 Ron Rousey
I think she comes back I'd be sick yep
we'll see all right kids enjoy the
fights on Saturday
uh as far as dates got a bunch of dates
coming up we'll announce them probably
later by the end of the week uh next one
I'll be at the comedy store Thursday
night get your tickets 8 P.M show at The
Comedy Store
um I'm just doing spot so it's not like
a bread and Shop toward official tour
day it's just a spot at the comedy store
I've been the Laugh Factory this week as
well so be around La if you want to see
me then next uh official one you got
shopping friends as a Pasadena Ice House
at 8pm July 28th Spokane September 21st
the 23rd Vegas skank Fest September 29th
through October 1st Niagara Falls New
York November 4th through the 5th I get
a bunch of dates coming up in August and
September uh I'll be announced at the
end of this uh week all right all right
kids love you guys be nice each other
thanks for watching like and subscribing
we got a bunch of content coming up so
make sure you stay tuned love you guys
see you next week